i don't know why he came all the way up
here
there's nothing left
welcome to your weekly ticket
john krasinski's a quiet place part 2
just became the
biggest pandemic era box office hit the
paramount film made 57 million dollars
over the memorial day weekend
which is roughly what the film was
projected to make prior to the pandemic
when it was originally set
to be released in march of 2020. aaron
taylor johnson has signed on to star in
another marvel movie this time playing
craven the hunter
this will be a part of the sony
cinematic universe and not the mcu
where last taylor johnson played the
character quicksilver in avengers age of
ultron
kraven is one of marvel's most iconic
anti-heroes who has encountered venom
and black panther among many others
and is one of spider-man's most known
enemies the film will be a solo movie
about craven and sony pictures has
scheduled the film to be released on
january 13
2023 warner brothers has set a remake
for
the hunger the 1983 vampire film that
was directed by top gun director tony
scott
the remake is all set to be directed by
angela robinson with a script written by
jessica scharzer
the original tony scott film was based
on whitley striper's novel of the same
name
and it starred catherine deneuve david
bowie and susan sarandon
in honor of pride month and rot tomatoes
list of 30 essential lgbtq horror films
we're taking a deep dive into all things
queer horror
and to help us break it all down i'm
joined
by the screenwriter of freaky michael
kennedy
michael thanks for joining us thanks for
having me this is a pleasure
now i want to know what is unique about
queer horror i think queer [ __ ] is one
of the last
sub-genres of four if not the last
sub-genre of four that is still
completely transgressive
in a lot of ways one of the last places
where you can be completely daring
you know because just living as a queer
person you're
automatically put in a political box by
a lot of people so i think a lot of
filmmakers that
play in the queer space use that to
their advantage and i think it's one of
the last places
in film really and especially in the or
genre where you can
you can do that and kind of go for it
in a lot of ways without having to worry
about what the studio thinks
or you know placating to a separate
audience i think it's
it's just an awesome genre and it's i
think it's on the rise right now too i
think
we're hitting a time where people we're
starting to see a little bit more of it
and you're starting to hear a little bit
less of the studios going
we already have our queer horror movie
you know because that that's something i
used to hear in the past
you know but you're hearing that less
frequently people are starting to play
in this space a little more
which is great what is it about horror
that lends itself to
you know speaking that sort of uh
message
i guess i think it's you know they go
hand in hand right you know [ __ ] back
in the day
um especially in the 70s and 80s
60s even like i said was transgressive
it was a genre
that was doing stuff that no other no
other genres were doing and they were
addressing topics that no other genres
were addressing and i still think that's
done today so it just kind of goes hand
in hand with queerness right like
it's kind of being a rebel even though
you you may not be choosing to be a
rebel but you're almost you know like i
said by being
born you're kind of making us you're
you're considered a statement to some
people
um and i think for me especially
personally and i think for a lot of
queer folks too
when we didn't have movies of our own to
kind of grasp onto or
call our own like explicitly queer we
were able to find
anything in a queer horror movie that
spoke to us
i think you could literally take every
horror movie ever made
and a queer person can put a queer read
on it
in some way whether it's the story
or the filmmaker or a character you know
i know for me personally i
really really identify with the sydney
prescotts and the lori strodes and
the quote unquote final girl because to
me that was the
closest in the 90s growing up as a 90s
team
the closest we had to a queer a queer
character with they were our avatars
so i think that's the beauty of four and
the beauty of queerness is you can
you can find your space in something
that's not explicitly gay
if that makes sense yeah it does that's
why horror is awesome because you can do
it with horror more than you can do with
any other genre
there's a lot of freedom in horror there
is yeah yeah
all right getting back to the list the
list of 30 essential lgbtq horror films
which movies from that list would you
recommend
if people are going to go and look at
the list they should watch all 30. like
those are all essential horror movies
queer horror movies especially
you got all the pride month that's what
like one one a day watch one a day i'm
telling you i when i was scrolling
through the list i was literally like i
would recommend every single one of
these movies
but i will shout out a specific few
night warning i want to recommend
because it's just so
weird and it's so crazy what came out
during like the height of the 80s
slasher movie when like i think a
slasher was being released in theaters
like every
week and it's so weird and it's so campy
and the story between the main character
and his aunt
is just so bizarre that it's just it's
like one of the queerest things you'll
ever see
and it's super fun the lead character is
really really interesting to watch his
the woman that plays his aunt is wild so
if you're looking for like
camp like high camp watch that the
classics like dracula's daughter
seat of chucky those kind of movies i
recommend just for the pure fact that
those are historic films
that you need to include in your queer
viewing canon
jennifer's body i think that's starting
to finally hit the mainstream about 10
years later
that's good that's crazy it's really
having a comeback isn't it
way ahead of its time and it's to me
it's probably the best horror movie of
the 2000s it's amazing
so amazingly gay so amazingly feminist
and megan fox has never been better if
society
could go back and do a redo that would
be the movie where we re calibrate our
feelings towards megan fox
and diablo cody and amanda scifri
because it's like the perfect movie it
just came out at the wrong time
and the studio messed up they marketed
it for like team bros yeah you know so
like
have they shown their cards a little bit
i think it would have hit the mark then
but i love that it's having a huge
resurgence now because it plays even
better now than it did 12 years ago
another camp classic that people need to
see
you have to see this movie and tell me
if you've seen it or not is hello mary
lou prom night two
i haven't it's wild it's so wild
it is so gay and it's also a
total reaction to freddy krueger because
the original prom night is a slasher
starring jamie lee curtis
and then the sequel is just a sequel
name only it's just called prom night
two and it's i don't want to spoil it
because it's so wild but it's got like a
freddy krueger type villain
instead where like the prom queen of the
50s dies and her spirit ends up in a
girl in the 80s
so she's like going around killing a
bunch of her classmates but she does it
in freddy krueger's
not in dreamscape but she does it in
very fantastical ways like freddy and
it's awesome
i love it i love it those are my big
recommendations but i have to say watch
all 30 of them watch all 30.
all right are you looking forward to any
queer horror films that are on the
horizon
um besides freaky too
god willing i mean my next movie is
pretty queer that's about to start
shooting it's called time cut but it's
pretty queer like freaky so i'm looking
forward to that
you gotta all right i wanna talk about
the babadook
and how the babadook has become an
unlikely lgbtq icon in recent years
hopefully you can explain that to
everyone and then also tell us what
other
film deserves that treatment kind of
like the urban legend of the babadook
and like kind of what i think happened
is
that movie just ended up on the netflix
queue one day
in queer horror during pride i think a
couple years ago
so people saw that and it became a meme
during pride about the babadook being
like a queer character
and so then people were memifying it
with within pride parameters and like
rainbows and
just all these queer different things
they were slotting it in really clever
ways
into already existing queer memes and
that kind of stuff
so it's almost like one of those
situations where it was like a
self-fulfilling prophecy like it almost
was like an accident
because there is like an urban legend
too that you know the people that like
curate the things on like netflix and
stuff they accidentally did it but it
ended up
spawning a life of its own so it's like
one of those instances where like is it
the chicken or the egg did the meme like
create the queerness of the babadook or
to the bob to
create the queerness you know what i
mean yep love it either way
yeah but when you go back and watch the
movie it's another example of what the
beauty of horror where when you start
thinking of it in that lens you start
seeing
a lot of the inherent queerness in the
film especially with a single mom
and probably her gay little boy you know
like the character is like sick so he's
not sexualized in any way but
you watch the movie and i know for me i
was like oh i was i was a little bit
like this when i was six that kid's gay
you
so know it's kind of taken a life of its
own but now it's like really embraced
and a lot of that movie has to deal with
grief too which i think for a lot of
queer people
is inherent in our lives just with
you know coming out you i don't know
like for me i definitely
had like a grieving process with my life
in a lot of ways because
you're playing pretend for a lot so like
you're
i don't know like there's grief involved
weirdly with
the process at least there was for me
but yeah so it kind of like it became
its own thing so now that
duck is like people love the baba duck
they love the queer
what like icon or horror movie do you
think deserves that treatment
that deserves to get i guess looked at
again do you know which one i really
wish people would embrace honestly
what's that is nightmare gnome sheet
three if you know the history of that
franchise
nightmare on elm street ii is actually
considered by a lot of people to be one
of the gayest movies ever made there's a
whole thing with that if you
after the show i'm telling you go google
that and you'll like you'll fall in a
rabbit hole
of just the history of that film he
wasn't openly queer during
the making of the movie but he was on
set and then the movie kind of
like his career so there's like a whole
history of that there's now a
documentary about that movie
there's a lot of controversy with that
film too because the writer and director
of that movie
kind of don't like depends on what year
you see an interview with them
one minute they're like we love that
it's a queer horror movie and then the
next are like we re
resent that it's um it's considered
queer so i bring this all up because
nightmare nom street three
to me is actually the queer nightmare
movie
and it's a beautiful representation of
queerness so
i want to see that movie wholly embraced
the way nightmare gnome street 2
is not only by the horror fans of it but
also like the general film
public nightmare 3 is about a bunch of
kids and shipped off to a mental home by
their mental
hospital by their parents they do group
therapy which is clearly disguised as
conversion therapy
and the seven kids band together to
essentially take down
not only freddy but essentially their
parents and society that force them to
go do something they didn't want to do
so it has a really
awesome story and it has a really
amazing like positive quick
representation where i think the queer
representation in nightmare too is
negative
all right well there you go get it done
audience we need to need the viewers to
to get this done
all right michael uh where can besides
the big screen where can people find you
you find me on instagram um it's at
michael tj kennedy
and you'll see lots of pictures of my
dog
well that's great all right well thanks
so much for coming on the show thank you
yeah thanks so much was fun
in theaters this weekend the conjuring
the devil made me do it
and spirit untamed
hey you okay there
jesus i think i hurt someone
the conjuring the devil made me do it is
the seventh film in the conjuring
universe
and reveals a chilling story of terror
murder and unknown evil
that shocked even experienced real-life
paranormal investigators ed and lorraine
warren
one of the most sensational cases from
their files it starts with a fight for
the soul of a young boy
then takes them beyond anything they'd
ever seen before
to mark the first time in u.s history
that a murder suspect would claim
demonic possession as a defense
and available to watch on vudu this week
is spiral
and profile do you know where your
officers are
working in the shadow of his father an
esteemed police veteran played by samuel
l
jackson brash detective ezekiel zeke
banks played by chris rock
and his rookie partner take charge of an
investigation into murders that are
eerily reminiscent of the city's
gruesome past
alright well that's it for this week but
before you go leave a comment and let us
know what you'll be watching this week
i'm kale and i'll see you next time
[Music]